geese versus lydia kallak versus speaker
hey so kalak not opting for his main
straight away he definitely knows
something about this because kalak
doesn't change characters because he
feels like it he definitely has
something in his brain here look at that
man i've never seen twilight conflict
looking so pretty man we're getting in
the tour but we're getting a tour but i
i do know why uh caleb has chosen to go
for the lydia he's been playing lydia a
lot generally in luck just in general
but against geese
against his strings lydia has a lot of
good sabacchi moves which can be used
effectively versus he so let's see if he
actually um is able to do that here but
holy cow look at that man i love the
little preview
crackers man surely they've got like
stuff to do man the place was falling
apart man
before he's just uh sitting around
dancing getting into the voice and stuff
man it is cool looking stage though i
like the the hue to it this is um
twilight conflict two
and you get the different music and that
um and a different color view
we're in the game now ladies
here we go again this is still first of
two action until we get into top three
so short sets here
will learn very quickly your play style
i'm calm about that
it's almost here perfectly here yeah
how to be cool careful doing a lot of
stuff against alex with the big power
crush when i push right through that
string here gets the second walls clap
it doesn't get much after it collect now
with rage answering back a little bit
watch the rage now oh yes
pika them young boy reactions man oh my
god yeah oh
no
block it once can't block it twice
and that sweet the little sweet bang
with uh lydia does so much damage just
have a look at how much damage it
actually does depends on like lira you
know
i love the lydia like character design
every hit that she has feels really
tough like it's just it looks like it
hurts to get hit with you oh god delayed
lone party coming out from colic right
now yeah
not much after it though
bumping straight away from pika pika
wakes up and jumps
so many plus frames good defense there
from cadillac rage available now
cadillac good punish from pika
trying to make this comeback
nice door
oh tried to jump up but kalik was ready
okay all right potential final round
here now best of three you do not want
to go down a game especially against
kalak right now tried to savage
yeah i'm liking oh man the hot kick
cadillac and that's something that he
will do quite often right he'll just
challenge you especially when he has the
round lead he gets the confidence and
look at that that should be the round no
round brown three round straight ladies
and lads cadillac
like he's going to eliminate pikachu yep
but we cannot come peek out pika plays
so many characters and just has such a
weird tech and setups all the way up his
sleeves man his sleeves are bulging
though with all of his uh kind of weird
tech and stuff so if anybody is going to
make this comeback now it is going to be
pika and forcing kalak into a character
switch i'd imagine kallak is not um
bound to lydia by any means whatsoever
and we didn't even see the sabacces
there to be honest though sam you know
so there's still so much more potential
for lydia to actually you know do damage
to gee so i think if you're kayak right
now winning three rounds straight there
without even using the tobaccos i mean
you're looking you're getting confident
here man so i think the only thing that
could that can make cadillac lose here
is if he gets overconfident if he's
overconfident then it could be gg's
hammer because pika will run away with
it but like yeah kalaka is looking super
strong here sound really yeah really
really really strong i mean it's a 3-0
pika just at all i mean the last game we
saw pika he basically ran through
another top eight contender um so uh you
know this is the caliber of tekken that
we're dealing with right now like very
very excited for this next battle let's
see what pika does now that he has the
stage pick in his favor
i can't imagine it's a character select
yeah okay a howard estate all right i
wonder i wonder is kay west watching is
he gonna let the intro rock we won't
even have here no because uh we're gonna
be uh look at that yeah this uh this new
stage thing man i want this can somebody
make a mod that i can install this for
my tekken game this is he usually he
usually does let the intro rock when i'm
commenting when cable says he doesn't
let it let's see if pika will do it this
time but
again remember he's
he's on the back foot here stamina he
loses one more matches out maybe he's
not even thinking about the intro he
just wants to get into this game asap
and get started have you got ladies and
gents second game incoming
do you believe do you believe i think he
can do it i think if anybody is going to
do it it's going to be our boy pika here
like you know yeah
let's see he's uh he's definitely
learning something there in the break
and between the games
let's see what he thinks oh we're trying
it
trying to just shut down some of this
pressure like alec is just
beating him up looking at the bounce
here are we about to see a perfect
working on it
looking for that okay hell man the
buttons on my word
that is not a good way for pika to start
this much especially if you want to make
this comeback seven goal the letters
cadillac
yep on his fourth round straight here
big low parry there
and pika wanting players that can
very easily tilt here um so uh let's see
if we can gain his composure back and uh
put some damage on the board maybe put a
round on the board you know and stop
this oh the stair down
that's terrifying
cadillac he's getting a bit bit too
confident i feel like here don't get too
cocky
nice all right feels them off the wall
here big damage here now and then answer
back from hika
let's see if we can put a round on here
oh oh okay
drops a combo oh he's angry now look at
these buttons
rage
there it is
nine years straight through knew he had
the hell to do it 11 seconds left on the
board and as pika reset the momentum's
bag that's the question i mean it's
definitely going to help man that was i
feel like his first round
so
you know let's see if you can ride the
momentum but kallak's still looking very
solid in this round
yeah okay
there's max mode now
i'm not looking to finish it here
carla is so patient man
yeah okay watch it pika now has uh
has access to rage bonus damage here and
he's got colic in the corner upon it oh
no i think that's minus 14 might have
been able to get more there okay nice
patience here
he got working his way back into the
comeback here 23 seconds left on the
clock
oh big l sweep
and the mid caught him ducking ladies
and gent away from eliminating pika from
the tournament
okay
back to the breakable now pika can do
some serious damage here oh but the duck
he knows it he knows it all right all
the way back to the other wall it
doesn't get much off in here full crouch
mix-ups
all calyx can smell the blood now it's
in the water pika needs to answer back
he needs to swim a little bit faster or
else caleb is going to take this very
convincingly here oh my god oh my god
no oh my gosh
[Applause]
i finished with a chip damage are you
serious he's feeling